wie ist die
Lage die Großwetterlage sehr positiv ja
freue mich wir sind mitten in der Tour
ist ein schönes Gefühl ich bin entspannt
Tour läuft gut Leute sind glücklich habe
gerade heute im Bus zu meinen Musikern
und Tänzern gesagt dass ich sehr
glücklich bin und so ist die
Großwetterlage das heißt ihr
Traumberuf ja ja ja ich ich habe in
meiner Vorstellung als Jugendliche nicht
so weit gedacht also ich hätte mal ich
hatte ein tr das war eine eigene
Schallplatte machen und der ist dann 88
89 in Erfüllung gegangen und weiter
wollte ich gar nicht dass ich hatte auch
nie den Drang irgendwie in die Charts zu
kommen das war außer meiner
Vorstellungskraft muss ich echt sagen
seit h es nie gereicht das war nicht mal
in der Künsten Traumvorstellung aber sie
haben sich schon dann vielleicht
unbewusst drauf vorbereitet indem sie
alle möglichen Tanzstile nachgemacht
trainiert und und und haben ja
wahrscheinlich unbewusst ich wollte dann
das war aber Mitte 80er Breakdance
machen das war diese breakdancewle da
saß glaube ich stand jeder vor dem
Spiegel mit weißen Handschuhen und hat
irgendwie irgendwas gemacht und ich
natürlich auch mit meinen Kumpels
zusammen und das wurde dann zur Passion
wir wurden immer besser und wenn du in
irgendetwas gut wirst dann fällt es dir
auch leicht da Zeit und Emotion
reinzuinvestieren wenn du spürst es geht
leicht und da ging es uns beim Tanzen al
so denken s manchmal es hat was mit
Schicksal zu tun wenn Sie heute
Produktion machen wo sie das alles
perfekt gebrauchen
können nein eigentlich nicht aber das
ist irgendwie so
es ein Weg der irgendwie ganz natürlich
entstanden ist das stimmt schon wir
mussten nie irgendetwas erzwingen das
ist dann einfach passiert auch im
Nachhinein bin ich froh dass die ersten
drei Songs die ich rausgeb gebracht habe
dass das Flops waren das war gut wir
konnten lernen wir wussten wie man ein
Plattenvertrag zu machen hat wir wussten
was man nicht tut und so weiter das war
alles gut aber natürlich in dem Moment
findest du das nicht so klar wobei ich
habe schon damals nicht als negativ
empfunden weil ich ja kein chartit mir
vorstellen konnte sondern habe einfach
gedacht wenn ich die Kosten wieder
reinkriege wäre super das ist wenn man
so anfängt so das er damals war das ja
noch Vinyl das war ja auch teurer so
eine Platte zu machen die muss ja
geschnitten gepresst eine matrizze
gemacht selber eingepackt jede
Schallplatte und nicht verkauft oder
kaum und nicht verkauft wo sind die
heute die sind also es gibt etwa 2000
mussten wir pressen und
800 sind irgendwo und 1200
hatten wir dann noch und jetzt im Laufe
der letzten Jahre haben wir immer wieder
solche Schallplatten versteigert oder
verkauft für ein guten Zweck und jetzt
habe ich noch etwa 100 okay waren die
denn wirklich wenn sie sehen war das
wirklich so schlecht dass es war es
berechtigt dass es Flops waren oder
fanden sie sich ungerecht behandelt das
war absolut berechtigt ja das hat
einfach noch nicht gereicht ich habe
auch an dem ersten Lied ein Jahr
rumgemacht um dann das abzuschließen auf
Platte zu pressen natürlich wollt es
keine Plattenfirma aber es war wirklich
nicht gut genug und aber dann mit mit
was neuem zu beginnen ich musste das
Abschließen für um dann was Neues zu
machen und habe dann sämtliche Kollegen
genötigt diese Platte von mir zu kaufen
für 6 € musste dann J du bist doch mein
Kumpel ja klar klar hier 6 €. und wieso
haben sie dann so lange durch also ich
meine drei Flops ist ja schon das halten
die meisten nicht
durch ja weil
äh ich weiß nicht vielleicht weil das
Ziel gar
nie also ich habe das auch nicht aus
floppenfunden ich habe das empfunden als
jede hat mehr verkauft die erste 800 die
zweite 1500 die dritte schon 4000 Maxis
und dann denkst du so ja jetzt bin ich
ja fast habe fast geschafft und
vielleicht wenn ich noch eine ma das ist
so ein bisschen eine Sucht und die die
vierte ging dann ich habe das nie so
empfunden als müsste ich aufhören ich
weiß nur noch dass ich damals meiner
ersten Frau versprochen habe also die
vierte die vierte wenn die jetzt nicht
die Kosten einpiel dann höre ich auf das
war damals also das wäre dann der
Karriereknick gewesen wahrscheinlich
also haben sie haben wir Haar scharf
Glück gehabt ja aber ich hätte ja ich
wusste ja wie nah ich dran bin also die
a habe ich die Kosten schon gesenkt
gehabt zu dem Zeitpunkt wusste schon wo
man günstiger produzieren kann als in
diesen Riesen Studios die man da hatte
und
B haben wir auch schon Einnahmen gehabt
welche über die Schallplatten
hinausgingen also man hat mich dann
schon als DJ gebucht und da habe ich
schon richtig Geld für gekriegt und das
habe ich natürlich den Platten zu
verdanken gehabt also ein DJ der eigene
Scheiben hat war schon was spezielles
damals und da habe ich dann schon
gewusst aha neue Scheibe gleich
Auftritte das gibt dann Geld auf einen
anderen Weg so ist es bis heute
geblieben was haben denn da die Eltern
gesagt ich meine DJ ist jetzt auch
genauso wie ich sag mal Schriftsteller
Bildhauer Sänger kein Beruf wo man denkt
oh das ist gut für meinen Sohn da kann
der sein Leben mit
durchstehen ich weiß das gar nicht mehr
richtig die wussten dass ich davon leben
kann also immer Unterstützung bekommen
nicht diese ich glaube es war eher
völliges Desinteresse von den Eltern was
die hatten sich nein die hat noch keine
Ahnung was der eigentlich tut die
wussten nur dass er irgendwie von 8 Uhr
abends bis morgens um 2 Uhr irgendwo ist
dann kommt er nach Hause und schläft
dann bis 10 oder was auch immer und dann
war ich ja jeden Tag wieder am Platten
kaufen ich war ja so vernarrt in die
Musik dass ich eigentlich jeden Tag
nach neuen Scheiben gesucht habe und
haben nichts anderes im Kopf gehabt als
Musik und war dann nachmittags schon
wieder in der Diskothek wie konnten sie
dann überhaupt eine Frau kennenlernen
wenn sie immer in der Disco waren übers
tanzen übers tanzen üb tanzen zwar war
ich habe ich Breakdance immer noch
parallel gemacht das ging ja auch gut
nachmittags und habe
dann bei den Deutschen Disco King Wahlen
mitgemacht aus dem einfachen Grund weil
da konnte man eine Reise nach Ibiza
gewinnen und wie kannst du dir a
19-jähriger eine Reise nach Ibiza
leisten keine Chance also ich wusste mit
dem Tanzen kein Problem die
Vorausscheidung in Memmingen irgendwo
die musste ich gewinnen und dann hatte
ich eine Woche Urlaub in Ibizza mit
gleichgesinden und ich kannte auch viele
die das auch so gemacht haben haben wir
uns abgesprochen du gehst dahin du da du
da dann gehen wir zusammen in Urlaub so
hat es dann geklappt und da in diesem
Ibiza habe ich meine Frau
kennengelernt ja und ihre jetzige Frau
haben sie auch beim Tanzen kennengelernt
genau aber dann später
94 93 Ende 93 da war die mega Dance Tour
da war headway Culture Beat t limited
und wir und sie war bei heaway dabei und
hat da gesungen und getanzt das war
natürlich super ja wie soll ich sonst
jemand kennenlernen muss man auch sagen
das ist ja wie viele andere
Berufsgattungen ich glaube ich kenne
auch kaum Ärzte die nicht irgendeine
Krankenschwester geheiratet haben oder
eine Arztgehilfin oder die die lernen
auch nicht
Fleischfachverkäuferin kennen und
heiraten die dann das selten so ja das
stimmt aber wie muss den eine Frau
tanzen wenn sie bei Ihnen ankommen will
sie muss nicht tanzen nein nein sie muss
witzig sein das ist bei mir ganz wichtig
ja ich kann keine langweiligen Mädels
ausstehen ich mag nicht ich muss so viel
Leute entertainen dann will ich nicht zu
Hause auch noch der Entertainer sein
also wenn sie auch so viel Lebensfreude
hat dann ist das recht gut also das ist
wichtig sie muss witzig sein ganz
wichtig wie machen sie das jetzt ist sie
auch mit dabei oder ja ja sie ist auch
mit dabei immer mit dabei und die Kinder
normalerweise auch jetzt
weil die Distanzen zu groß sind morgen
ist Stuttgart heute Hamburg will ich das
den einem zweijährigen Mädel und
sechsjährigen Jungen nicht antun das ist
aber die sind begeistert ja ja absolut
mein Sohn ist jetzt eben Sex der kriegt
das richtig gut mit der war schon als
Baby mit auf Tour den hat dann einer ein
Musiker und Tänzer nach dem anderen hat
die Kinder jeweil rumgeschleppt und
unterdessen nehmen die Musiker dürfen
wenn sie wollen auch ihre Kinder und
Frauen mitnehmen und dann ist das ist
bei uns ein riesen
Zirkusunternehmen als nächstes kommt
wahrscheinlich noch ein Lehrer mit damit
alle Kinder Unterricht haben ich finde
das Sch schön
weil dieses Familiengefühl das geht
schon verloren auf so einer Tour und
wenn dann Kinder da sind dann gehen die
Erwachsenen auch ganz anders miteinander
um also der Ton untereinander ihr werdet
das dann auch spüren wenn ihr euch hier
bewegt der ist sehr anständig sehr ruhig
die Leute gehen sehr respektvoll
miteinander um und wenn die Kinder da
sind eben noch mehr ja so meinen sie hat
schon so ein febel auch für ihren Job
bekommen also tritt er in ihre
Fußstapfen vielleicht manchmal spürt man
ja sowas ja ich spürre
nichts ich nein er er findet das alles
super und es gefällt ihm aber ich habe
ihn schon ganz früh versucht ans
Schlagzeug hinzuführen und in diese
Richtung man gucken ob ihm das Freude
macht aber er spielt sehr
gerne Tennis Fußball spielt gerne mit
Rittern das ist eher so seine Welt sch
ein bisschen diese Fantasiewelt auch und
dann Sport mag er ser gerne also das war
ja bei ihn auch früher ein Schwerpunkt
Sport Fußball sie waren Kapitän im FC
oder wie kiken genau mein Dorfverein ja
also vielleicht in dieser Weise trifft
tritt er dann in ihre fußsta das find
ich besser muss ich ehrlich sagen ja
weil ich weiß nicht dieses Geschäft hier
dass ich auf diesem Niveau betreiben
darf das ist schon nicht hat nicht mehr
viel mit Leidenschaft und Freude und
super und lasst uns Freunde sein zu tun
da werden die Ellbogen schon kräftig
ausgefahren bei uns also in diesem
Business auf dem Level es ist kein
Freundschaftsspiel mehr das sind alles
Meisterschaftsspiele hier da geht's auch
um sehr sehr viel Geld also jeder Tag wo
wir uns bewegen bewegen wir auch viel
Geld und das ist auch eine große
Verantwortung und ich weiß nicht weiß
noch nicht ob meine Kinder in die
Richtung auch geschaffen sind das weiß
ich nicht wie sieht wie sieht das mit
den Ellbogen aus wie wie kommen die an
ja gut man muss sehr aufpassen in
unserem Geschäft gibt's sehr viele
Parasiten die sind eigentlich wird sie
das an wir wie die wie sagt man das
Licht die Motten ja ja wir sind das
Licht und und das saugt sich alles an
was irgendwie profitieren will sei das
finanziell oder emotional oder und da
muss man ganz klar versuchen zu
trennen muss ich nicht in die Karten
schauen lassen muss auch hart dealen
können wenn es Verträge geht und das ist
nicht jedem sein Ding ich habe schon so
viele
Verträge gesehen ich kenne unterdessen
die Löcher ganz genau wo wo eine
Plattenfirma Gewinne verstecken kann und
wir nüzen ja auch schon seit 10 Jahren
die Industrie als Vertriebsnetz wir
finanzieren alles selber wir machen die
Videos und das hat ein Vorteil man ist
selber Chef hat auch den Vorteil wenn es
super läuft verdienst du mehr wenn es
aber nicht läuft hast du keine Deppen
dem du die Schuld geben kannst und der
dir alles bezahlt also ich kann dann nur
allen Künstlern sagen es ist ein Abwegen
auch unser Weg ist nicht der optimale
manchmal wünschte man sich schon auch
jemand der einem ein bisschen hilft
dabei gut vielen Dank ich wünsche Ihnen
noch viel Erfolg danke auch